we have the right to for freedom of the
press and freedom of photography hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with reason TV and today
we're talking with Jerome Voris a
student at Northern Virginia Community
College resident of Alexandria and the
reason we're talking to you is because
you got into a little scrape with the
police Jerome tell us what was going on
july of 2010 i was walking through
georgetown and i came across a traffic
stop so I thought that just for
collection that I could just write that
I would just take a couple of shots of
the police talking to somebody that they
had stopped absolutely of the police
officers engaged in a traffic stop and I
proceeded to take my photos and it took
a couple and then when I moved to the
other side of the street I was
immediately stopped by one officer and
they asked for security reasons why I
was taking pictures told them that I
just wanted you know to have photos for
collection and that officer skated
around my question of was I being
detained or not I eventually came back
and said no but by that time another
officer came by and she requested my
identification and in fact said that I
was being detained now and these were DC
City cops yep and as a result of this
the ACLU the American Civil Liberties
Union is bringing a lawsuit against the
the police what's the basis of the
lawsuit the basis of the lawsuit they're
bringing against the District of
Columbia and four police officers
individually is that I was detained
unlawfully and that my First Amendment
rights were violated and that's because
you you know in fact you weren't free to
leave if they were holding your
identification absolutely the officer
took my ID and therefore I was not
what's the status of the case now
because this it happened a year ago and
what what's going on now well we just
filed suit last Thursday in US federal
court in the District of Columbia at
that time the District of Columbia had
20 days to respond at this time he has
not responded to our lawsuit however the
District of Columbia right before we
were war right after we filed the
lawsuits in my lower yard Spitzer an
email saying maybe we can settle this
out of court unfortunately at that time
we had already filed the lawsuit so what
are you hoping to get out of the lawsuit
what I hope to get out of the case is
law enforcement nationwide not only in
the District of Columbia know that
photography is not a basis for
detainment in that you have to have
reasonable articulate able suspicion to
detain someone the Constitution is the
Constitution the First Amendment is
clear and that we have the right to for
freedom of the press and freedom of
photography photography its freedom of
speech as well and this of course is a
growing issue at reasontv we've talked
about about this a lot and as citizens
are more and more armed with cameras and
everything from their smartphones to
their iPods etc this is only going to be
more of an issue why do you think the
police are so upset at having pictures
taken of them while they're doing their
jobs I don't know I only could speculate
that maybe they don't want citizens or
members of the press to document what's
happening are you deterred by your
running with the with the law or are you
dedicated data taking photos all the
time I'm dedicating out of taking photos
more than ever to show law enforcement
in my new process it said I don't I
don't only want to take pictures i also
want to educate officers who I come into
contact with the photography is not a
basis for detainment and that they
cannot legally detain someone for taking
photos well Jerome Boris I think you're
going to have a lot you certainly won't
be running out of people to talk to for
the next you know 100 or 200 years
thanks very much for talking with us for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie